you know what they call a coffee tasting
they call it
cupping cuppy yeah so they say oh I was
just cutting with a friend that's hard
yeah I like cutting coupling cup and
clicking hard absolutely
hey hey hey how you doing hey how's it
going all right I'm two chinese jeremy
nice to meet you I need you to what's
going on today so we have selected the
world's ultimate coffee brewing and
coffee setup for you to try today
it is it is it more french vanilla or
more of a roast type of I'd say it's
more on the vanilla side a little bit of
cherry to the fruit
oh yeah and had too much of it I'm not
sure if I like that in my coffee but
what do you got here talking about
dessert this is actually a Kopi Luwak
coffee which is sort of famous
throughout the internet the history of
this is basically these animals in the
forests of Indonesia civets gone out and
eaten the coffee cherries and so the pit
that we roast and turn into coffee comes
out the other end in their poop I guess
somebody's walking around the woods and
said oh hey that that's still good
inside of the and the poop it's a still
good let me try that and it's kind of
become its own little thing some people
are really into it this coffee is
collected from poop it it is so it a
poop this one's about $600 a minims $600
$500 a pound yeah there's $600 douche in
the machine comes with it right absolute
so this is the blossom brewer it's a
starts at six thousand dollars all right
this is where this damn machine yeah
yeah that's right so what does this do
what what is it it talks until you come
in touch you have an alarm we're working
on having it be your best friend that's
this United for six thousand dollars she
should jump cars off this [ __ ] should
have an air pump on it
let's just have XM radio that would be
cool I'm issued write down these that's
why doesn't my I got this this is a 2
Chainz edition yeah you say I'm Exim has
oh this is like a bottom or has
yeah oh yeah see these are your recipes
so what we have programmed in is
specific for each coffee we're gonna
brew today we have a recipe that matches
exactly to them so we'll use this coffee
first it's like the UM would take about
a house it's a house in that that's
right we're gonna put a whole zip in
that street to be a good cup you know
what a zip is uh kind of sort bit mostly
okay this is a Mel Koenig ek 43 grinder
it's more consistent than almost any
other coffee grinder ever made there's
actually entire blogs dedicated to this
grinder this one right here yeah so this
is Rhonda so you can really put a grande
anything you wanted it that's what I'm
so this is a ser enzyme so just pour
that in the day today they go together
yep both of them for six dollars uh
that's three thousand so nine thousand
for both that's it Brooke yep I got a
little psycho weed right here to you
okay just stir it back and forth like a
paddle yeah
all right that's enough stirring there
okay so I got my homie with me right
so hey bro come here check this out for
now this man here has better yeah meet
your pie fish are not yet nice to meet
you yes but you can throw it
hell yeah here you go you know because I
want my to like two of my biggest pinkie
rings I want to like do you advise us to
to to leave the pinky how uh you know
that's really a matter of personal style
assuming for me I'm more of a pinky in
many many are pinky out so I'm even is -
is it a level of degrees in bhujette
yeah he's like further out your pinky is
it's more [ __ ] I think so more
[ __ ] it - multiplies it really how
much is this right here this cup uh in a
cafe that could be a twenty to fifty
dollars what is this cup of coffee bicep
I got worried you're looking at you know
a hundred to six hundred dollars a pound
for the ladies we've got a couple
dollars a sip okay yeah a little first
cuz young man I hate burning the roof
mum oh it's amazing
honest it's good honest right cheers
Cheers no pink it 90 degrees boss Scotty
he's up is this the most expensive one
right here the most expensive is the
Kopi Luwak well I want to try that cuz
this always meant nothing to try too
much as me yeah yeah I know we got it
iku so if you wanted to buy all those
things for your home you're going to be
out ninety four hundred dollars for this
setup but you know what better way to
wake up in the morning all right let's
do a deal right now let's do a deal
lifetime supply kick for today but put
in 94 yeah we are getting the three
pounds of coffee can we negotiate their
purse
absolutely finish which we doing servlet
trust no we're all good we got we've got
our special civet coffee ready to go
catch it cat cat [ __ ] coffee let's do it
Kopi Luwak does it live up to the hype
cat shake hockey cat [ __ ] coffee babe
pinky in on this one can you taste the
difference
hey uh no hey there are cups of Kopi
Luwak there as much as $100 served in
various cafes here in the world so these
these cups of coffee should come with
[ __ ] - sure I know this question
about the X sounds like oh no if it's a
smart question on a dumb question what
if you have like cat allergies can you
train this I can't you drink this coffee
like that's some deep bite that's a
pretty quick that's a good question it's
been asada CAD pan mm-hmm yo man look
I'm up all night
start recording maybe one at night so I
can't even lie coffee is something that
I hadn't been doing my whole life it's
like a recent thing it's like I'm trying
to balance my vices like if it's not
skittles then it's coffee I try not to
do both but anyway is really really good
means you cool do the most expensive
coffee maker and talking about let me
get one for the studio I already know
how to boys kicking it pinky up
90-degree Real Player [ __ ] you're
giggling
will you pay for this most expensive
coffee that I cat ate and [ __ ] it you
let me know leave a comment I'll let you
work